في مواجهه خصم من نوع خاص بعيدا عن خصومه
السياسيين التقليديين فالخصم هذه المره
ممثله اباحيه ابت الا ان تجر رئيس جمهوريه
السابق الى ردهات المحاكم الحديث هنا
بدفع اموال لارغامها على السكوت عن علاقه
غراميه قديمه بينهما القصه تعود الى سنه
2011 حين تحدثت
عن اقامه علاقه غراميه مع ترامب سنه 2006
وتحديدا بعدما التقت به في بطوله خيريه
للجولف ورد ترامب حينها كان النفي لكن
الموضوع تغير سنه 2016 حين ترشح ترامب
للانتخابات الرئاسيه التي فاز بها فيما
بعد فقبل الانتخابات بشهر واحد وافقت
الممثله الامريكيه على حد قولها على
الحصول على مبلغ 130 الف دولار نظير سمتها
عن الحكايه برمتها والمبلغ تحصلت عليه من
طرف محامي ترامب حينها مايكل كوهين
لكن الممثله الامريكيه انتظرت سنتين بعدها
لتظهر في احد البرامج التلفزيه وتتحدث عن
القضيه وعن العرض الذي قبلته بسبب تهديدات
محامي ترامب وحينها اعترف كوهين ان ترامب
امره بدفع المبلغ وهو ما اقره فعلا الرئيس
الامريكي السابق الذي نفى في الوقت نفسه
هذه العلاقه مشيرا الى ان السبب دفع
الاموال لستورمي هو رغبته في وقف
اتهاماتها الكاذبه والابتزازيه ليس الا
الموضوع لم يغلق حينها وظلت التحقيقات
مستمره من طرف الادعاء العام في منهاتنه
ويواجه ترامب تهمتين الاولى دفع اموال من
اجل ما يسمى شراء الصمت وهو ما يعاقب عليه
القانون الامريكي وثانيها احتمال خرق
قوانين الحمله الانتخابيه في حال كان
المبلغ المدفوع قد سحب من اموال الحمله
وفي انتظار التعرف على اخر تطورات القضيه
فالاكيد ان ستورمي احدثته درجه كبيره غطت
ولو مؤقتا على الحمله الانتخابيه للتراب
وسام الذهبي العربيه